[Musique]
c'est moi amélie
ma voisine ne respire pas je n'arrive
pas à ressentir son pouls est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres membres de la famille qu'on
pourrait contacter des membres de la
famille
je peux à peine m'occuper de moi
c'est à responsabilités assumées et
musique
je suis ta soeur ne plus que toi
touba
salut
musique c'est ton ami et beau
je suis votre voisin emménagé ici
tu sais elle comprend absolument tout ce
que tu lui dis et si tu es heureuse tu
appuies sur celui là je suis très drôle
petit van ryn sa façon de voir le monde
est complètement différente de la nôtre
va se faire une soirée pc je suis
heureuse
[Musique]
auto
sa maman
[Musique]
tu vas y arrive
et je vais l'aider tout quand
tu vois je suis en train d'apprendre à
aimer vraiment lorsque je
et
[Musique]